a record 100 million people forcibly
displaced the uan says the war in
ukraine has pushed the world into the
staggering milestone but will this be
the wake up call to resolve other
conflicts this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hashim
akhalbara it's being called a record
that should never have been set the un's
refugee agency says more than a hundred
million people have been forcibly
displaced around the world the figure
was reached after the war in ukraine
pushed at least 14 million people from
their homes
while the unhcr praised the
international response to help
ukrainians it's urging the same level of
compassion for other conflicts and
crises rights groups have criticized
western nations for failing to welcome
the vast majority of displaced people
from africa the middle east and asia the
un's high commissioner for refugees says
the figure is a wake-up call to resolve
global conflicts
there is not just ukraine that we should
not forget all the rest
first of all because ukraine has an
impact on many other
fragile situations making it more fraud
making them more fragile food security
energy crisis
price increases
instability and then this
in turn can cause more displacement if
you have countries getting into unrest
and into
political
fragility you we may see more
displacement so it is very important as
we respond to ukraine and we will
continue to
to also pay
adequate attention to crisis in africa
crisis in the middle east crisis in
latin america crisis in asia and so
forth let's take a closer look at the
numbers
by the end of last year at least 90
million people were displaced mainly
coming from ethiopia burkina faso
myanmar nigeria afghanistan and the
democratic republic of congo and ukraine
this year
and they mostly want went to countries
like turkey jordan uganda pakistan
lebanon germany sudan bangladesh iran
and ethiopia the major causes are still
conflict violence and persecution
followed by natural disasters
but weather related events like storms
floods wildfires droughts and extreme
temperatures
are becoming a growing trend
let's bring in our guests in nairobi
nazani mushiri senior analyst for
climate and security in africa at the
international crisis group in uppsala
sweden jasper bjarnasen senior
researcher at the nordic africa
institute and in london vatinaya
professor of migration studies at queen
mary university of london
welcome to the program
nothing in a staggering milestone we're
talking about 100 million people
displaced more than one percent of the
global population let's talk globally
before we move to different parts of the
world
why is this
staggering
increase in the number of displacements
i think there are a number of reasons
for this displacement um i think as you
mentioned there conflict of course is a
major driver here
um in africa
in the democratic republic of congo um
in ethiopia um in the horn region
we have uh major conflicts ongoing and
that is a major driver
but there are other drivers too um as
you mentioned there
climate in terms of climate stresses the
extremes this the weather that we're
seeing the ongoing prolonged drought
here
in the horn region
uh we're seeing uh major weather
disasters as well storms cyclones
flooding um in parts of the world those
are also major factors which are leading
to this staggering figure but you have
to remember as well that a lot of these
people have been displaced time
and time again so those figures are
staggering that many people have been
displaced and are moving
either internally within their own
countries for example here in in south
sudan here in the horn or moving across
borders as well
yes but 38 million
internally displaced people reported in
2021 14 million ukrainians
displaced you're getting a sense that
this is showing no signs of abating at
all
well to some extent i agree with that um
unfortunately we've seen
an ever-increasing number of displaced
people uh globally
and i think i agree with natalie that we
have to look at the drivers of
displacement and really
focus on what is what is forcing people
on the move under those conditions and
there i would also emphasize that
there's been a complete a more or less
complete failure in
in halting armed con
i work mainly uh in west africa and
we've seen rather the opposite the
escalation of armed conflict
with displacement as a major consequence
of these armed conflicts so yes those
are sort of worrying trends and worrying
figures but i would also just want to
mention that
we
we rely a lot on cr for our
understanding of displacement dynamics
and they do a fantastic job not just in
interventions but also in collecting
data but there is this tendency also
that
as a charity based organization they do
need to emphasize this ever-increasing
number it wouldn't look good uh you know
towards donors to say that the trend is
actually reversing so i just want to
caution
against the narrative that also really
pushes this
idea of an ever escalating and unending
crisis okay parvati do we have to
spend more time now focusing on the
drivers or the triggers when the they
combine because
we have wars conflicts autocracy climate
change
and you get a sense sometimes that the
international community is doing nothing
to try to
tackle this issue
thank you thank you for this question i
think
you know it it is
not exactly true to say that the
international community is doing nothing
in
2018 we had you know two major global
compacts which are not binding legal
agreements but nevertheless you know
sort of commitments by countries um to
both address questions of safe orderly
migration and also the question of
cooperation around refugees
but i think that these compacts and
agreements
good as they are are taking second place
or third place even in international
priorities
and i think this is the problem uh i do
think that
it's it's good to have a good
understanding of drivers and triggers
but to talk in terms of drivers and
triggers alone is not enough
i think the international community in
particular the wealthier
countries of the world the global north
if you like has a responsibility to
really look at the way in which
development is being propagated across
the world globally and to really have a
much more people-centered and
planet-centered approach and that is
vital if we're actually going to find a
way forward because today it's a hundred
million and that means you know one out
of 100 people maybe in the world
but that means also that
tomorrow it will be you me and everyone
else we know so i think it's very very
important to have a very different
systemic approach to the question of
human uh displacement speaking of those
approaches nazanin when you look at
somalia and you see because of the
ongoing conflict the number of displaced
has been on the rise at the same time in
ethiopia because of the conflict in
tigre
but then the african union the
international community have not really
been
able to step in in a way or another that
not only would put an end to that those
problems but bring about a permanent
solution to those conflicts
yeah i think access is a big issue and
also the fact that when you're talking
about these these uh disasters i guess
the focus is on immediate humanitarian
aid and it's not often on sustainable
solutions
which could be brought about by
building resilience you know to climate
issues for example
in parts of these country countries so
access in integra
as you know is a real issue access in
areas large sways of somalia
are controlled by al-shabaab in the
south and central part of the country so
how can you even access those areas how
can you build sustainability when you
are not in any dialogue at all with with
armed groups like al-shabab so that is
part of the problem
yes but when you look at the war in
ukraine and the global attention
you just move forward to places like
western africa or the sahara region
where the
the challenges are massive we're talking
about a vast territory
larger than europe on its own and with
the increase of instability we're
talking about a potential for millions
and millions of people to be affected in
the in the future however you don't get
that same sense of urgency and attention
as far as the international community is
concerned
i would agree with that observation i
think the ukrainian crisis has brought
out something that is
not new and not particularly surprising
which is that europe prioritizes people
closest to its own borders but also
people who are closest to sort of
europe's own vision of itself if you
want so there's a racial aspect there
there's a cultural aspect there's a
linguistic aspect so it seems much
easier for european public opinion to
sympathize with ukrainians displaced
than for example with people from mali
or burkina faso
and i think that's something we have to
acknowledge
and i also think that that
europe has perhaps have i mean i europe
is an important uh
donor region in the world but i think
europe has had too much of a say in the
global conversation around uh refugee
protection for example and that is
actually not really in line with the
realities on the ground i mean more than
80 percent of the world's displaced
people are actually hosted uh in the in
the global south so i think that the the
european understanding of who is worthy
of solidarity and protection shouldn't
be the only voice in that conversation
parvati
how to move forward because you get a
sense
that
the international community
is having an issue particularly when it
comes to impunity you look at places
like yemen like syria other places
millions of people were killed hundreds
of thousands of people displaced and
ultimately the international community
is not doing what it should to prevent
those atrocities from being
uh
done again and again
uh absolutely i would agree with you i
think and i agree also you know with uh
what has been said just now
about the fact you know that the the
ukrainian displacement horrible and
tragic as it is uh is nevertheless
actually um only what is the a recent
tip if you like to this massive iceberg
and uh you know the vast majority of
displaced people are in what you know in
developing countries and many are in of
course africa but also latin america we
have venezuelans we have you know cubans
we have a large number of people on the
move in latin america in in asia of
course the rohingya crisis has been
existing for a long
long time so you know wherever you go
now there is that there is the presence
of the refugee the internally displaced
the migrant but there has been a
distinct prioritization
which is of course racial as well as to
do with european identities
particularly here in the uk for example
it's very interesting that the uk
government has on the one hand opened up
a channel whereby you know uk citizens
can offer a home to ukrainians but at
the same time they are working on a deal
with rwanda to uh send across mainly
those who have been coming across or may
come across from the channel
from france and of course we know that
many of them are from
conflict or post-conflict zones from
africa from iraq etc so we see a very
clear distinction and i think that that
uh honesty is absolutely necessary on
the table um and yes i also agree that a
lot of the measures have been responsive
or in reaction to rather than really
tackling what is a global phenomenon
international human rights organizations
ngos operating on the ground
they raise the this issue for the for
for a particular reason they want it to
come to an end and they don't want to
see a repeat of it
but sometimes the urgent
need is for
donations for donors to step in to
provide assistance tackle what they they
can tackle now when it comes to inviting
people to look at the
root causes of the problem that's where
people say you know what this is really
going to take ages and ages to solve
yeah i think that's definitely a huge
issue um and i concur with um what was
said on the painful contrast between
the way that ukrainian refugees
have been treated
and the way that refugees say from
somalia or syria have been treated um i
think one of the issues that hasn't been
raised possibly is the fact that
what is happening in ukraine
um is having a massive impact on uh the
potential for that aid that's
desperately needed
right now um here in the horn where i am
and also of course um in the sahel
region as well
um if we just take somalia for example
somalia is really reliant on uh wheat
from russia and ukraine even before the
war heavily dependent on imported rice
vegetable oil sugar fuel
and this has had a major impact on
prices i think food prices have
increased by more than 140 percent uh in
somalia
which is extreme so when you look at the
aid that's needed to help people who
have been displaced and the costs of
that aid the figures don't add up it's
impossible to really know how that gap
will be filled and i think this is a
huge huge issue and a big big worry for
people who are uh trying to help the
vulnerable communities have been
impacted uh by these many issues right
now yes but since this doesn't raise the
issue of the global dimension of the
conflict in the ukraine now
if this continues the potential for
because ukraine is one of the biggest
exporters of grain to the to the world
if it continues and the disruptions
continue we're likely
to see more instability violence and
hunger in
in africa for example and then the
potential for more disbasement to happen
it seems that this is going to invite us
to rethink the way we deal with crisis
particularly those with a global
dimension
um
well i definitely think that
both the the unfortunate milestone of
100 million displaced people and the war
in the ukraine is giving us sort of
another occasion to
reassess the way
international
interventions and responses are modeled
and i do think that that there is a need
for a more holistic approach to to
displacement crisis i think we've we've
already mentioned the the centrality of
the drivers behind the displacement um
one one thing i would like to emphasize
both in terms of country conflict
prevention and in terms of responses to
displacement
is the immense capacities of local
communities in the areas that
experiencing displacement to actually
host displaced people and and sort of
make do
outside the purview of state
intervention or the presence of
international organizations so i think
that in terms of the
broader
approach to to responding to these
issues i think there's need more
acknowledgement of the immense resources
and and sort of efforts made locally
very close to the displacement
situations around the world uh where
local communities are actually receiving
people housing them providing them with
opportunities and and i think that
broadening the the view to also include
development efforts to to strengthen
those communities is a way to make the
responses more sustainable over time
parvati a milestone is a number 100
million remains a figure in number
in fact we're talking about 100 million
stories shattered lives shutter dreams
stories of
eviction and dispossession
yet
yet once again
you get a sense that the the world cares
more about figures
not the stories of the people who are
the most vulnerable
you're right and it is a problem
we live in a world where there are many
instrumental
approaches and priorities
and numbers somehow fit in better than
stories
i just want to say one thing yes it's a
hun you know we're talking about 100
million lives and stories of
displacement and despair
but those hundred million lives as long
as they are alive are also 100 million
lives of hope
and i think it is absolutely fundamental
and i thank you for flagging up the
humanity that is at stake
and the great loss for all of us across
the planet if we do not invest if
governments do not invest
more attention more funds more resources
more support for these 100 million
lives that our lives of great promise
and future it is a great tragedy because
many of these are young people they are
the future of this planet and so it's
absolutely fundamental that we humanize
the the refugee and displacement story
i also completely agree that we need
local authorities to be taken into
account ngos
questions of place it's the law it's on
the ground in particular localities and
places and regions that you know the
actual support and
resilience is happening and so it's
absolutely fundamental to take into
account that um
meeting point if you like of people on
the move and places that welcome
and there are some good examples of this
for example in italy where we had mayors
making you know arrangements amongst one
another when the government was going
off in a completely different direction
so i think there is this great potential
that needs to be paid attention to and
tapped into
climate change is definitely going to
become a bigger bigger issue in the
upcoming years more scarcity of water
food particularly in the african
continent could this be the moment to
change
or shift priorities at least as far as
the african union is concerned because
they talk about a deadline to silence
guns when i think now it could be the
moment to think about how to tackle
climate change and its repercussions
absolutely um we've been waiting for a
few years now for the african union to
appoint
a climate
envoy um and they haven't done that yet
and this year is really significant for
the african continent for example
because cop 27 will be uh in egypt and
many are
saying that it is going to be an african
cop so it's a really important time and
a key time for africans to have their
voices heard
but just looking at climate change and
climate stresses um when we talk about
migration in the sahel or here in the
horn um it's it's been a long been a
part way of life for people here
migratory movements across borders um
have been the norm particularly for
herders but what we've seen in terms of
the impact on climate
on these movements is the droughts in
particular that we've seen and recurring
droughts have reduced the ability of
these
populations to move um because they're
left without the resources necessary to
move um and this is a huge huge issue
for people
who live a semi-nomadic way of life and
with these longer dry seasons that we're
seeing an increased pressure on water
and land we're seeing a shift in those
movements and that is going to be a huge
issue in terms of bringing people into
potential situations where they could
end up in conflict
yes but the
the issue of droughts long cycles of
droughts have been straining relations
between herders and farmers ethnic
groups in africa but it's also creating
problem for host nations in different
parts of the world let's give you an
example in niger for example has its own
problems and then it's flooded with a
huge number an influx of
refugees and displaced people and people
are saying we cannot handle those
problems anymore
that's right as i said before i mean the
the majority of the world's displaced
people are hosted in the global south
and many of those
regions and communities are also highly
vulnerable in uh among for among other
reasons because uh of of sort of
environmental degradation for example
through droughts um
and and i do just want to emphasize that
despite that vulnerability uh people are
still sort of stepping up to that
challenge and we've re i mean we do see
some
uh conflicts arising from the arrival of
of displaced people but we also see a
lot of solidarity on the ground and i
just want to emphasize one more thing
which is that
in in sort of uh thinking about the
narrative around refugees globally i
think the
key issue in the solidarity we've seen
around people displaced from from the
ukraine now is that they are not only
offered asylum they're also offered the
opportunity to work and what we see for
example in in relation to the syrian
refugee crisis which has been going on
for years is that uh fairly well-off
people with a certain degree of
education are kept waiting in asylum
procedures for years without being able
to work or contribute on their own which
is what most people in the world want to
do so i think that in terms of of the
responses we need to think about whether
it's in the sahel or in europe we do
need to think about how we can sort of
encourage systems that make that allow
for people to create their own lives
under these new conditions and we will
definitely continue talking about this
particular issue in the near future at
least hoping that one day
that staggering number of people who
have been evicted from their homes
will decrease nazanee mushiri yasba
bjarnsen pavati naya i really appreciate
your insight thank you
and thank you for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story for me hashimoto and the
entire team here in doha
bye for now
you